Thanks to fortnight by epic games for
sponsoring this video.
Check out the link in the description to
download and play fortnight for free.
What's up wisecrack jared?
Again,
if you guys haven't seen the torrent of
tweets,
Netflix,
new show,
the haunting of hill house is getting
some serious notoriety.
It's got a 93% fresh rating on rotten
tomatoes and some people are saying it's
so scary,
they're puking their guts out seriously,
which brings us to the question in a
genre as bloated as horror.
What makes another story about a haunted
house stand out?
While we could point to the casting
camera work or one of the best jump
scares I've seen,
we actually think it has to do with wait
for it.
Ghosts.
All right,
I know,
but what makes hillhouse rise above
shows like American horror story is a
duality of the ghost metaphor that is
incredibly smart.
So grab those adult diapers and join me
for this wisecrack quick take on the
haunting of Hill House and yes was head.
But before we get into it and want to
give a shout out to our sponsor over at
epic games,
they're the creators of this really
addicting game.
You may have heard of called fortnite
hop on a battle bus and had to an island
for the ultimate battle l'oreal.
I actually recently downloaded on my
phone and I'm digging it so to download
the game for free,
head to the link in the description and
stick around till the end of the video
to hear more.
All right guys.
First a quick recap.
The show follows the cranes during their
stay at the haunted hill house in the
1980s while the parents,
Olivia and hugh are trying to flip the
home.
Mother and I,
we have to finish fixing this house and
then someone has to buy it 50 years
before it was trendy.
The kids spend the summer being
irreparably traumatized by a series of
terrifying events.
This all comes to an end though.
When the father rushes the kids out of
the house one night.
What the show portrays is some spooky
hunting business from the perspective of
the children is eventually revealed to
be the suicide of the mother.
Flash forward to the presence and all
the children are still living under the
shadow of their past.
Steve,
the oldest is a successful,
albeit cynical author writing about his
paranormal childhood.
Shirley is a tightly wound type A
mortician.
Vo is a clinical psychologist with some
serious intimacy issues.
Luke is a junkie 90 days clean and his
twin sister now,
well now's dead and it's her death that
starts off a fresh batch of hauntings.
If those character descriptions haven't
tipped you off already,
the heroes and hill house aren't your
typical cookie cutter characters and
other horror series,
but to understand how they're so
different,
we first have to understand an idea and
writing called the ghost,
which has been explored by the author K
and Weiland as we'll see what makes the
haunting of hill house so good is the
blurry boundary between Weiland's ghost
as technique and the show's ghost as,
oh my God,
what the fuck is wrong with that kid?
As for wildland scopes.
The idea is this at the beginning of a
story,
our heroes aren't usually the greatest
people.
They can be jealous like woody and toy
story or selfish like ebeneezer scrooge
and a Christmas according to wildland.
At the heart of these personal feelings
lies a basic psychological mechanism in
which we value survival in one aspect of
our lives over survival in another.
In other words,
we'd lean into certain beliefs even
though they might make us unhappy just
so we can survive.
And the reason why we formed these
beliefs,
Weiland calls this your ghost though
other authors,
we'll call it your wound or simply your
past trauma for woody in toy story,
his ghost or trauma is the knowledge
that unloved toys are discarded causing
his jealousy of buzz,
which blinds him to his unsavory
behavior.
For Scrooge,
his ghost is the poverty he experienced
in his childhood,
which later causes him to be the penny
pinching man.
We all know blinding him to the fact
that he has ruined his life.
What he and scrooge up to protect their
wound fear and poverty respectively at
the expense of everything else.
In the haunting of Hill House,
it becomes clear that the actual ghosts
are some kind of metaphor for the
horrifying events the crane family
faces.
Chevron are,
Mike Flanagan expertly leverages each
character's past trauma or ghost to
explain why our heroes are so messed up
as adults.
Steve witnessing his mother's friend
mental state firsthand rationalizes his
whole childhood as a product of mental
illness.
In fact,
he's so convinced that his family has a
genetic mental condition that he gets a
vasectomy right out of college.
I was there something wrong with our
goddamn brains.
So yeah,
I'm never having children.
I made sure surely who takes in a box of
kittens as a child only to have them go
dead and crazy demonic becomes
fascinated with the way morticians fix a
person making a corpse seem alive again.
That's what I do,
unsurprisingly.
She then becomes a control freak.
Mortician as for Theo,
her special ability to understand the
essence of something by touching it
backfires when she touches her mom and
sees a rotting corpse.
And how does the o turnout as an adult,
she flexes her ability to help people in
her day job while wearing gloves in her
free time and having shallow emotional
relationships.
And Luke,
well,
Luke's substance abuse stems from
watching his mom poison and kill his
childhood friend and from the various
obsessive coping mechanisms he developed
to distract himself.
Like any good story though,
the haunting of hill house builds out
it's conflicts by having characters
confront their trauma.
And this is the part where we get to the
literal ghosts of the show.
Now there's a seriously large grab bag
of ghosts in the series.
In fact,
if you look hard enough,
you can see a random ghosts lingering in
the background of almost any shot.
And while there's a whole cast of ghouls
that have almost nothing to do with our
characters back stories,
the most memorable ghost or the
personified embodiments of our
characters,
past traumas in psychoanalytic terms,
we could view these literal ghosts as an
example of splitting where people
splinter off and repackage the negative
parts of themselves or others,
nor to maintain a positive sense of
self.
It's like Weiland said,
it's all about survival except in the
crane family's case.
The unconference did trauma manifests as
actual ghost.
The literary ghost becomes a literal
ghosts.
It's in the red room where all these
literal manifestations of trauma come to
the fore.
It's real is like the heart of the
house,
not a hard to stomach.
And the series closing episodes,
all of our surviving crane children
converge in the red room.
We're the house puts them each to a
mental test.
They must confront their literal and
metaphorical ghost.
For Steve,
he must confront his concern over his
family's tainted blood line when he
experiences a room 1408 moment and is
transported into the future,
or he got out of Hill House alive,
complete with a happy pregnant wife.
That is until he realizes he never left
the house and his wife's baby becomes a
literal rot splitting open her stomach.
Yeah,
it's pretty gruesome.
Surely on the other hand,
must confront her inability to fix
everything,
including her personal shortcomings.
And she does so by reliving her own
secret affair.
You did it any light in and you just
decided not to look at it.
Now that's all over.
Charlene never wants to look.
Things are even worse for Fiona.
She grapples with her self imposed
emotional isolation while on the bed
with her casual lover feel loses her
ability to feel anything at all and a
thousand hands drag her down.
And Luke,
well Lucas transported back in time back
to the tea party with his mom,
his twin now,
and his childhood friend Luke glimpsing.
A life without the pain of addiction or
the death of the three people closest to
him is tempted to sit down and give it.
That is until Nell saves him go.
Okay,
why would you want your brother to go,
hey,
just got here,
have a seat.
Don't exactly as she saves all the crane
children by pulling them out of their
nightmares.
Now,
some of you might think that Nell
swooping in is a Dsx Mokena ending,
but as story guru slash wise crack
favorite Dan harmon would tell you,
the characters in this portion of the
story have earned it by confronting the
worst parts of themselves in their past.
They've grown as people and the universe
is responding by throwing them a
lifeline in the form of now.
Case in point now literally forgives
each one of them before stressing the
importance of love,
forgiveness like a tear on a cheek.
Thank you for that and then for me when
you stand in the rain.
Okay.
Hmm.
I loved you completely.
You loved me the same.
That's all
the rest is confetti.
After Nell,
the father exchanges his life in order
to free his children and the group
escapes having conquered both their
literal and metaphorical ghosts.
The cranes then go on to lead fulfilling
lives,
free of the supernatural.
Steve reconciles with his expect and
wife.
Shirley comes clean with her husband.
Feo throws her gloves away and commits
to a real relationship and luke hits the
two years sober mark surrounded by his
siblings in showing us these happy
endings.
The haunting of hill house is firmly
making a statement that there is light
in the darkness,
that trauma can be overcome.
It's like what Steve said about fear
feel to it where we find it,
we cannot meet halfway and if surrounded
by family or love,
perhaps we can face it directly.
So what do you guys think is the
haunting of Hill House?
Really that scary is it's use of ghosts
that much of a departure from the horror
genre.
Well drop us a line in the comments and
let us know and if you're too scared to
sleep,
there's nothing better than
decompressing by shooting people in the
face.
I'm talking about Fort Night.
It's free to play and so easy to
download on pc Mac,
ps four xbox one switch ios and android.
Jump on Oh battle bus and head to an
island.
The last man standing wins the game.
You could also customize your
experience,
dress up in different skins or collect
customized weapons.
Obviously my favorite thing are the
dance moves.
There's nothing quite like trying to
stay relevant with the kids by threading
or whatever.
This is if you can play solo or duos and
squads with friends for nine is always
adding new things to the game.
So even if you're familiar with the
fortnight verse,
checkout all the new cosmetics they've
added for season six and this includes
pets.
If you're ready to play,
click the link in the description.
And as always,
thanks for watching guys.
Please.